[Music]
Lounge Connor was one of the poorest
counters in the country it was 80
African-American and in 1965 no black
people registered to vote in Lowndes
County Alabama
people were followed people could lose
their jobs they were literally putting
their lives on the line all that because
you're trying to register to vote and
they still organize we wanted a movement
that would survive the loss of Our Lives
[Music]
the white establishment saw it as a
fundamental threat we saw it as a
fundamental necessity
this is a play for power
we live in a world that is so heavily
shaped by that movement
we have to continue to tell the story of
how we got to where we are today
[Music]